so thank you for welcoming for your last
session of the quarter just before I
start going to the presentation I would
recommend you follow the wonderful team
at bolt threads I'm sorry if you have
the misfortune of following me on
Twitter you'll mostly get raged tweets
about the Seahawks games and things like
that and so I'm gonna tell you about the
company I started after graduate school
called bolt threads but before I can get
into what bolt is and some of the things
I've learned I kind of have to give you
a little view on how I view the world
and why why there's a problem that's
worth solving here so planet we live on
earth about four and a little over four
and a half billion years old if we look
at fossil records life has been on this
planet for I say four billion years is
actually like 3.8 is the current
estimate but I always say what's 200
million years between friends and if you
if you think about us Homo sapiens we've
been here for about 200,000 of those
years we've got some ratio twenty-three
thousand to one up there I actually like
an analogy as a way to understand this a
bit better so if you say earth is about
one day old
humans are about 3.7 six seconds old and
the decimal points really matter on this
when you're talking to us too big ratio
and and what astounds me is that in that
time that we've been here on this planet
in two human lifetimes 150 years humans
have had a dramatic impact on every
aspect of this planet climate change is
the one that comes to mind but whether
it's changing the changing the the
hurricane season to be more intense
wildfire season as we experienced here
just a week ago or covering the planet
and pollution and waste products we are
having a big impact and we've done it
incredibly quickly and adding to that
problem and the next by the end of this
century we're gonna add several billion
more of us to the planet this is baked
into the pie it's pretty much inevitable
and the truth is a good chunk of those
11 ish billion people who are here are
going to become middle-class consumers
and that's good no poverty all sorts of
good stuff on the downside they're gonna
eat like middle-class consumers buy
stuff like middle-class consumers and
throw their crap away like
glass consumers much like we do here in
the United States and so the question a
lot of people have to grapple with going
forward is can this planet support about
three billion more middle class
consumers and about four billion more
people going forward and it's a honest
question and I think there's a there's
an interesting thing you can think about
here of some of the limitations of
resources so I'll use the the arable
land example so right now arable land
where we grow our food and we feed all
of us it's great it works we've got
about five percent more arable land we
can go and add new crops to and grow
more food but if you just take that
population growth and number of middle
class consumers and look at 2050 you
need 70% more arable land and
unfortunately this is not like adding
servers to your cloud infrastructure
this is like LAN we don't make more of
it now maybe some woke up with a crazy
idea but it seems a little little
far-fetched so I actually want to ask
you guys a question you know knowing
this how many of you show hands are
optimistic that humans will be here
thriving ten thousand years from now
couple of you okay we'll make it a
little easier a thousand years hands
anyone else okay now the easier question
hundred years we gonna be here alright
so everyone's putting out that we'll be
here in our years right I'm actually
incredibly optimistic that we are smart
enough to be here and thriving ten
thousand years from now and it's it's
it's not because I have blind faith
there I'm just a dreamer it's that I'm
trained as a scientist and I believe in
the data and I think there that that the
example is there in front of us of what
we harness to be smart enough to do this
I believe what we can measure improve
and here's here's what I always come
back to for that 3.8 billion years that
life's been here it's done okay like we
just screwed it up in last hundred fifty
like look at all these things that
biology has done it pervades the planet
huge amount of diversity I'm showing you
it's called a phylogenetic tree here but
the idea that everything comes down to a
common ancestor which yet to be agreed
upon but everything from your fungi and
your animals to your filamentous and
cyanobacteria your photosynthesizers
there's a huge amount of diversity
and this all went along just fine for
you know basically 3.8 billion years -
150 before we really came along with our
modern society and the thing I find
amazing about biology this is like it's
almost reads as a sci-fi tech even
something as boring as a flower biology
covers the planet in every possible
range of ecosystems from snowy and
Arctic to subtropical or desert it self
reproduces all of our modern products
that we've learned to make widgets
devices your iPhone if you chuck in some
sugar water your iPhone doesn't
reproduce it just shorts out you throw a
seed in the ground it grows it makes
more seeds and it makes more stuff it
repairs if I cut and I'll show an
example this later if you cut something
off of a tree it grows back and and can
you imagine describing to someone oh so
I'm a show a short video here this is
forest floor nothing really happening oh
now it's moving a little bit
time-lapse not in real time and look
something is growing out of the floor
growing too many times its height it's
then going to sprout some flowers and
look pretty and blow in the breeze and
if you describe this as a technology you
were going to invent out of a entry
level engineering class people would
tell you you're crazy it can't be done
this co2 sunlight time don't freeze it
works that's absolutely amazing biology
is powerful and and me as a bio engineer
see this as an example of something that
can we figure out how it works not just
watch it and say wow that's pretty but
use it to solve some of the problems we
have on this planet and here's what's
really changed a lot in the last 15
years and to the layperson who's not a
biologist it's been less obvious this is
one of many things two ways to convey
this but DNA sequencing is a really good
way to show how this technology has
changed dramatically
you can talk up this is reading DNA
technology this is you look at the ast
season G's within the genome of every
living organism on the planet and
understand how it stars information that
makes it do everything from eat
digest things to make new versions of
itself to self-repair and as this cost
has gone down from you know 100 million
dollars a genome to about a thousand
bucks a genome it's enabled a lot more
engineering capabilities design build
test cycles and there's a now I can show
you analogous data for writing DNA code
for synthesizing those AST c's and g's
as well as some of the more esoteric
tools and and computational
functionality that's critical there and
so I actually think modern bio engine
modern bioengineering is truly
engineering and going there quickly and
it liberate sus from the canonical ways
we think about materials in particular
across our planet and energy so that
we're not going to be reliant on 18th
century solutions to 21st century
problems and so the one big problem here
is that all of our modern economy is
built on a absolutely amazing material
that is fundamental everything we do and
that's oil and oil is amazing I'll show
you in the next slide when we get there
it's kind of neat it but there's no
amount of optimizing that current
economy to sustainability for ten
thousand years
we're either going to burn it all up
we're either gonna release enough
greenhouse gases that we unleash to fill
full fury of climate change or we're
gonna drown ourselves in pollution of
things that never degrade but as I said
it's actually quite useful it's made
some really awesome things you know
everything from dry you think about
driving your cars and stuff like that
but everything from paving roads to
making plastics and over the last 50
years plastics unsurprisingly have grown
dramatically because they're cheap they
last a long time and they're very good
at what they do in fact you find them
touching every element of your life
including I'll be willing to bet
ninety-five percent of you are wearing
plastic fibers right now the challenge
with that is that it's designed for a
product that you use for a short time
but lasts a long time and our future
looks something like this when you
create something out of a polyester or a
nylon or an acrylic plastic you're
putting something out there that you're
going to use for anywhere from
I don't know drinking straw for a couple
seconds two minutes and it's gonna last
for a few hundred years there's a big
impedance mismatch between the material
and the product and and how long it
lives and that's actually only the part
you see take your clothes two-thirds of
the fibers made on this planet every
year come from plastics primarily
polyesters we make and consume about
eighty billion per dis about a hundred
billion now garments per year across
this planet has an insane number and
it's only going to get worse and those
plastic fibers when you look at your
yoga pants your t-shirts your sneakers
they're all there and they take hundreds
of years to degrade what's even worse
and our friends at Patagonia paid for
this study and we have a partnership
with them and give them a lot of credit
for calling out something where they are
part of the problem as well and they
know it when you wash your garments that
have polyester fibers in it small micro
fibers smaller than a millimeter break
off and go down the drain and there this
data is showing you is like a per six
kilogram washed load how many with the
count is of those microfibers not only
do they come off in the water but they
actually go slip through all the way
through the waste processing plant out
into the ocean where they're eaten by
small organisms like plankton which are
eaten by fish which are eaten by us and
there was actually a great article came
out about two months ago quantifying the
amount of plastic microfibers in poop of
humans across every continent in this
planet and it's like 95 percent of us
have it it's actually is such a new
problem we don't even know if it's bad
for us or not like I think it is but we
don't know we just kind of know the
problems there now but if you ask me
this seems kind of unsustainable right
how do we go fajn a planet where we
consume 80 billion garments a year that
effectively never go away
whereas you turn around to look at how
nature does things and it makes
materials that are designed for four
billion years to biodegrade in the
environment and I found this one I'd
throw this up here just to point out the
absurdity of some of the things we do
you know fruit is great there's a term
guy goes bad faster than fruit because
fruit actually biodegrades
we've actually been so crazy as to make
things like things that look like fruit
at a plastic that will never go away
this is absolutely absurd
so I think you know nature is incredible
there's a problem here with materials
nature solved a lot of problems for
billion years that's a lot of like what
exists today but everything that came
before it that we can find out there and
when they when nature makes a material
it stores it in the genetic code like I
kind of alluded to earlier and so I'm
gonna give you an example here one that
I think is drives the point home a
little bit show you a few things that
nature makes so this is a barnacle I'll
be surprised if many of you have seen
one of these before but maybe you
haven't they mostly slit crustaceans
they stick to the hulls of ships and
piers and things like that and this is a
blown-up version here they basically sit
there and they're filter feeders trying
to eat stuff that comes by have no brain
have effectively no way to move around
except for in the early part of their
lifecycle but they've essentially
evolved and adapted over time a glue
that they make and secrete that cures it
within salt water which is actually a
really rare feature and they stick to
the ship and not even you know no
hurricane no amount of driving fast
takes them off you can come there with a
hammer to bust them off we as scientists
chemists chemical engineers we haven't
made things as good as that in our
hundred years of supposedly being the
smartest in the world so this next one
I'll show you is it's another different
material where nature's of all something
cool and I'll do this in two phases one
because I a gratuitous hummingbird video
because I like hummingbirds so this
hummingbird is flapping its wings sixty
times a second that is kind of crazy
right
does anyone tried to move their arms 60
times a second you can told you ever
hurt yourself it's it's it's absolutely
amazing so how did how did nature solve
this problem and the better example to
show you guys is we'll take this
dragonfly does the same thing but it's a
better understood system so this
dragonfly fairly small that's wings that
are about the length of its body giant
lever arms I don't see big burly muscles
to move its wings 60 times a second and
it you know in her short lifespan she'll
flap her wings about 300 million times
what she's done is gone and evolved
effectively protein based rubber bands
that's it in the joints of the wing that
are 99% energy efficient so she's not
actually putting a lot of energy and
she's just kind of keeping them bouncing
over time that keeps her alive and
that's absolutely incredible did we
don't make rubber nearly that good
anywhere on the planet from
petrochemicals so my personal favorite
where bolt started the silk that spiders
make so what you're looking at here at
the video I'm going to show you this is
called the Darwin bark spider she's
about a gram not the smartest critter in
the world spins this protein based fiber
that we call silk it's very similar to
the silk we use for apparel over the
years and it's fine it's biodegradable
I'm gonna actually back up and play this
again okay it's fine biodegradable it's
actually stronger tougher than Kevlar by
about seven fold it's absolutely
incredible material she's not
intelligent about it she just had a four
hundred million year head start and so
what she's doing here actually this is a
really cool feature that spiders do this
is called ballooning she's releasing
this silk it's wafting across a river
it's gonna catch on the other side it's
about 30 meters wide and she's gonna
build a web over that River to catch
bugs that come up to make more baby
spiders and that that's the power that's
one of the most powerful things you can
imagine on the planet when you look at
biology and it actually gets far better
than that because this silk is actually
out of one of six or seven kinds depends
on the species that she makes that have
different features
one stretchy like spandex another you
think of a spider's web it's sticky the
stet silk is not sticky she actually
makes a glue from a different gland that
she coats onto those fibers there's
another one that's super soft there's
one that's very very fine but all in
she's already provided a roadmap for how
you would make a wide array of fiber
based polymers and so I think about you
know the technology that makes these
guys tick they they make our modern
devices look like rocks that we carry
around and talk into I think this is
amazing with everything that they can do
and spiders are really where the bolt
story started
so we came along and said you know what
there's a lot of these features out in
nature they're often made from proteins
much like the fiber we have here from
the spiders the glue the barnacles make
the the rubber in the insect wings all
incredible materials all made from
proteins and proteins are kind of the
core competency of biology when you
study biology there's something called
the central dogma it's about information
stored in DNA to functionality largely
in proteins the search space is about
basically 22 the end is the number of
amino acids you have in there so it's
effectively quickly becomes a basically
infinite so I founded bolt threads in
2009 with two of my buddies out of
graduate school with the idea of using
proteins to replace the plastics and
other materials we find out there in the
environment and so I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about how we do that before I
talk about some of the things we learned
along the way so step one everything
start in DNA find word from finding the
information you want and copy it out and
I no longer get to do this because I've
been able to find people much smarter
than me who work at all probably many of
your colleagues over the years who come
work with us so Rina here kind of
typifies what happens in a biology lab
ranging from finding the information in
an organism doing a little bit of
tweaking and coding to make it work
better in a new organism we use yeast
that's actually what she's looking at
here on these plates single-celled
organism actually we as humans have a
very long and passionate love affair
with East for several thousand years
we've used it to make cheese bread beer
wine things we love all over the world
and then we have essentially yeasts that
are tuned to make the spider silk
protein without any spiders then we need
to make a lot of it turns out that
growing scale up is always a thing for
startups growing a lot of these plates
is a real bad idea so we turn to another
yeast kind of technology called
fermentation where we use large
stainless steel tanks and there was a
time when I used to say this was a giant
300 leader stainless steel tank now in
bolt parlance this is a baby little
fermenter that's cute and we run it
around our place normally when we're
doing scale-up now these things are
about 20 feet in diameter about six
stories tall
and that's we mass-produced metric ton
scale quantities of spider silk protein
then and I'm not going to show it here
it's kind of distracting but we take it
take the protein make it into a powder
much like a powdered milk or a whey
protein like after a workout to dissolve
it into a viscous liquid and extrude it
like you'd make rayon or polyester into
fibers and one of the things we've
learned over the years is that if you
give people a pile of polymer or a pile
of fiber they don't really know how to
interpret it so you make things that
people actually interact with so in
about a year ago we did this it was a
limited edition drop this is a wool
spider silk blend sixty percent wool 40%
spider silk that we did in combination
with a friends of ours at best made
company and it basically makes this
beautiful soft yarn that we knit into a
product that actually turns out to be
about 30 percent warmer than wool by
itself while being about 10 percent
lighter and so we made this making a
product and we actually took it all the
way this is the idea of getting minimum
viable product all the way in the hands
of consumers by making something putting
in a FedEx box and showing up at a
doorstep
turns out the hardest part of the whole
thing getting through customs in Russia
another example so we work with the
designer Stella McCartney and in early
last year the Museum of Modern Art in
New York commissioned a piece for for an
exhibit they were doing we're still a
design this dress and then we came along
and made it out of 100% spider silk and
the museum displays it as a piece of art
for about six months before now I think
probably gonna end up on display and
want to Stella shops at some point but
absolutely incredible and what it does
it starts to ignite the imagination of
what can be and that this can become
real product it's not just a science
experiment that it's going to turn into
things people can interact with and buy
and as we continue going forward the
mantra is scale you're gonna see this in
a lot more places starting next year and
beyond
so the good news about this it kind of
sounds sci-fi like Tom said in the
beginning it sounds like you're
venturing into the unknown and that
you're gonna you know try and launch put
a man on the moon for the first time or
do something absolutely crazy and it is
a bit crazy is that I won't deny that
but we're following a playbook that's
been optimized over billions of years
you're copying something that already
exists so I look at this the beauty of
biology and the four billion years
evolution to use us your crib notes is
that you get two big advantages that
other product developers chemists and
others before you never had and this
should never go understated you have a
working prototype in your hands like I
can well not right now it's too cold the
spiders roll did but it's Charlotte's
Web fall whole thing but we can go out
there when there's spiders and webs we
can take a piece of the silk we can put
it in a mechanical tester and we can
test those properties right there's a
working functional 3d composition of
matter that works for this stuff so like
you know that and second you know that
biology can manufacture it so if you can
engineer biology you too can manufacture
it with that small caveat there is it
doesn't tell you how hard and how long
it's gonna be how many millions of
dollars it's gonna take but it can be
done and and I would venture to say that
that is a massive cheat when you're
going off and starting something new so
we have another product we announced
earlier this year that I'll talk about
briefly a problem material on the planet
for sustainability this is one that
actually is from nature leather
everybody loves leather who doesn't love
leather there's some reasons not to love
leather I'll cut to the chase there but
a wonderful material has evolved affect
effectively with humans over the years I
love a leather jacket as much as the
next guy although it has some problems
I'm not a vegan but from a sustainable
materials point of view besides just
killing a cow that is a really
inefficient way to make that material
you could do far better so if I have a
jacket like this raising the cow to make
the left they make the hide to make the
leather there's a three year process the
economics of leather of the hides is
absolutely terrible it's actually
considered a waste product and during
that three years that cow is taking a
pasture space it's eating a couple tons
of
grasses that are using water and land
and all sorts of stuff
cows are expelling greenhouse gases in
the form of methane from their belches
which is about 20 ish 25 times more
potent than co2 alone and it's
essentially fueling global warming let
alone once you have the hide of a dead
cow you have to go through a tanning
process to do what's called deep
eutrophication it's the word of the day
and tanning hasn't changed much in the
last 600 years some of them look a
little nicer than this we used to do a
lot of hide tanning in the u.s. it's
terrible toxic chemicals lots of salt
smells awful and so what we've
essentially done in the US is export all
of this pollution to other parts of the
world that look something like this and
there are fancier versions but largely
that so when I look at it from a
renewable resources point of view what
you have is a 600 year old solution that
just makes no sense so bolt we actually
announced earlier this year where that
we're making a leather product and I've
got one that you guys can touch up here
if you want and this is a this is a
leather it looks like leather feels like
leather but it's made from growing
mushrooms so we grow take a mushroom and
it's the part you eats called the
fruiting body most of the organism grows
in a dense network of roots called my
cilia we grow these my cilia on waste
products actually from the silk process
and create a leather that grows in nine
days not three years and eliminates all
of the harmful chemistry's in the
tanning process it's durable it's
functional no animal involved and
mushrooms are kind of kind of
fascinating right these are things that
grow on waste products like cellulosic
biomass there's some of the biggest
organisms on the planet I find this
actually pretty incredible if you go you
can actually take a road trip up to
Oregon and see this you know two
thousand acre single organism you know
pop quiz trivia for pub night is a
largest organism on the planet it's not
a blue whale it's a fungus and so what
we do it actually is grow it in a tray
so this is potentially woodchips or
manure or something like that corn
stover is what we
in particular and then what happens is
this missile iam the fine root structure
we trick it and it grows above the air
we crea create a foam in about nine days
and then we use that compress it cook it
diet and you get something that looks
like this looks like cow leather but
like the silk is a completely circular
material comes from products from nature
can be read i jested by natural
processes across ecosystems on the
planet and that's pretty incredible and
it bolt we have a whole series of new
things that will come after this and so
these two are just the beginning of what
we're doing we were really started as
three science obsessed nerds who were
driven to avoid getting full-time jobs
when we were going to graduate and what
we've evolved into is a company looking
to solve some of the most vexing
material science problems on the planet
and the best news of this whole thing in
my opinion is you don't actually have to
trust me you have to look at a working
functioning system that's been here for
four billion years and trust that track
record and so far we only have nine
years of experience but I'm gonna go
into a short section where I talk about
some of the things we've learned about
reinventing a category so bolts a weird
company we blend consumer meets
molecular biology and effectively no one
else on the planet really does that so
here's a couple of things I've learned
one and this is this seemed dumb and it
feels a little maybe even overused but
everyone forgets it that when you're
starting a start-up I think the most
important thing you can decide on as
early as possible is why we call what's
your North Star and and that's to say
what's the thing you want more than
anything that you're willing to
sacrifice on other things to get there a
really really smart person in in
start-up land once told me that the true
strategy is the things you decide not to
do not the things you decide to do
because it's easy to say yes to a lot of
things it's hard to say no and give up
the things that come they come with it
so first and foremost simple point but
absolutely pivotal and it bolt for us
it's a it's actually about our mission
driven nature
people joined bolt because of the the
ability to take amazing new technology
in an exciting new commercial space and
do something real good in the world if
we make it work and so we actually
reduce that down to little will slogan
we have that we're inspired by nature
devoted to science and driven by an
optimism that the best days of the
planner for made ahead of us and that
that's something that everyone who comes
to bolt really buys into and it makes it
easy to say no to all the other things
along the way because we know we're
saying yes to the second thing I'll
point out is about recognizing
opportunities I think oftentimes people
think that like opportunities are either
they have to be completely obvious or
that people get lucky I would say that
each of you are smart enough you know
amazing opportunities and it's all about
the execution to get there and so I'm
going to show you this is a vintage 2011
bolt threads then called refactor
materials series a pitch slide we raised
five million dollars in our series a
back then and it was about the benefits
of why you'd want to make silk this way
and we're mostly one but whatever the
idea here is that you can make with a
mated process you make more consistent
fibers than when nature makes them you
can control cross-section we thought and
we all we're know now know you can make
these fibers machine washable and then I
added these two things so like people
should care about this sustainability
and the fact that they don't come from
animals I got laughs like literally
laughed out of venture capital pitches
because of this right they were like
like I might be as green as the next guy
but I've never heard of a vegan material
today there's like a billion dollars of
demand coming to the bolts door asking
for these things and no one cares about
these things so that we the point here
is not that like venture capitalists for
dumb is that there was an opportunity
just wasn't clear that the market and
the need had all lined up in a way that
everyone understood it yet and that that
we had the right idea just the right
timing and that by being flexible and
knowing that there was an opportunity
there we were able to harness that later
on the second part of this was where do
you use silk and so my slides are a
little backwards here but all the way
I'll explain this is if I tell people
were making spiders
the first thing I say is make
bulletproof vests and it's probably
because I seated it in your mind by
comparing it to Kevlar and being tougher
earlier turns out probably a terrible
idea you're taking a business risk on a
market space application that literally
no one's ever done with that material
before and so you're compounding risk
upon risk that's cereal whereas if you
look back for about five centuries I'm
sorry five millennia sorry
silks been used as a beloved material in
consumer products in apparel it doesn't
have the long timeline and technical and
regulatory risks that come with some of
the other spaces and it simply required
us as a bunch of engineers to kind of
check our egos at the door and say this
isn't what feels like the most technical
application out of the gate
but turns out so it's about a five
billion dollar a year market which is
not really what we go after right now
silk fiber itself we go after other
stuff within the fibers market but there
and as you dig into it there were really
interesting technical problems to solve
and really interesting sustainability
problems to solve and then after we saw
that we can always come back and do
these other crazy things people asked us
to do like make semiconductor
dielectrics sailboat sails medical
devices beauty and automotive nothing
stops us from doing that in the future
if we get the business right in the
beginning the other part I'll point out
is Milo so a year ago this was not
really a big part of bolt at all and it
was a recognition that there was a
massive opportunity in the market here
that the right technology at the right
time with our team could be huge and
today the demand is actually I've
stopped taking calls on Milo because it
the demands through the roof and people
will pay anything for it this one little
self-serving because I'm a scientist but
I argue that treat entrepreneurship like
science make sure you're learning from
everything you do every everything you
do can be designed to learn something as
a failure even in failure and so I would
give a couple basic examples I think of
I've got a four year old son and little
past blocks and holes but trying things
actually ask the question gather the
data analyze it and use that to inform
your decisions running off of other
people's wisdom and instinct is rarely
the right option and usually you can
design good experiments that allow you
to make data-driven decisions on how to
build your company and how to go forward
I'll skip over this one competition so
when you kind of lay bolt out there in
the world of startups you could think
about what exists with similar materials
you've got your natural materials your
synthetic and if we think about it the
bioengineered and we're not the only
ones who thought of this idea of using
biology to engineer materials in fact if
you go start googling around you'll kick
up companies like these ones and you'll
say oh they're your competition you
could like fight them and block them
with IP and like all these other things
and they've got like pretty pictures
kind of like ours and like maybe this is
this is this is all our stuff over here
but maybe this is a problem right the
reality is most startups don't die
because you have competitors like we're
all a bunch of startups who are burning
cash and trying to like figure it out
the biggest competitor is ourselves the
most likely chance a compass startup
fails in my opinion is the team makes
bad decisions and runs out of money and
can't make payroll and so any good just
to you that's like the most obvious
thing but everyone forgets it so like I
often advise everyone at Boalt look
internal not external for where that
work the worst competition is and make
sure that we're testing the right things
and being prudent with our path forward
so that we can make our product and our
technology real turning a technology
into a business this is a tricky one
especially for scientists and engineers
you know we're all good with technology
at some point you have to find a way a
way to make money doing it the Dan just
go raise more money answer only works
for so long even though I've heard
people say that it Bowl dan will just
raise more money and so so you know the
question here is like I would argue that
that Netflix did this brilliantly of
finding a way to take a technology and
marry with a business model in a way to
devastating effect to the rest of the
marketplace and so when we look at this
at bol
we have a business model that in the
traditional sense but many will told us
to do was bolt makes stuff and then we
give it to someone who's like a
middleman who makes things like fabrics
and materials and then they'll sell it
to brands and you'll monetize by
basically feeding the pipeline in these
people eventually pull that turns out to
be terrible and there are a million
reasons that doesn't work and there's no
incentive great technologies die all the
time here so what we did it bolt was
kind of hybridized the business model
where not only do we make things we take
it all the way to the consumer like that
hat I showed you we made a series of
neckties we actually like this muck this
bag actually we had in Kickstarter a
little while ago a few examples here of
stuff we've done and like I said I read
about being a scientist these are all
experiments we designed these to learn a
lot in everything we do from how do you
design packaging how do you ship
something to what archetype of customer
is interested in following us how does
it map across social media space and an
e-commerce and it's all about getting
out there and doing lots of tests really
really quickly and I often tell people
within the company that humans are worse
than random and predicting the future
but we are far better at seeing and
recognizing it and so let's just make a
lot of things and let's recognize where
it's working what you should care about
this is a little nebulous but you start
a startup this is what the headlines are
going to tell you you should care about
so these are some things that were
written about ball turrets it's all
about dollars right everyone cares about
money no one cares about the rest of it
in public perception but much like that
North Star argument I made in the
beginning you you need to know what
you're going for and learn to ignore
this and it's harder than you think it's
really difficult everyone gets caught up
in this raising money financing says we
all understand money and the fungibility
and being able to do things with that
but in reality like it all comes back to
this like we we care about this
internally and if we do this right all
of the capital all of the money will be
there and the last thing and this is
just small
as an entrepreneur no one is going to
tell you how to do your job better than
yourself and the great entrepreneurs in
my opinion find a way to self motivate
for myself it's how you caused enough
anxiety enough motivation to channel all
of your energy into making the business
go forward so the example here is um you
know if you put yourself in a boring
office situation every day it's pretty
hard to motivate yourself to do extreme
things to make risk-based decisions
because you know bolt that no amount or
stay won in your startup no amount of
cutting costs will get you to
profitability you're gonna have to make
risky decisions and take chances to get
there which I imagine if I was hanging
upside down in a rock like this you're
pretty motivated to make some risky
decisions if you have to so those are
the a handful of things I've learned
[Applause]